CBS News spoke to a Democrat and a
Republican on the Senate Intelligence
Committee and they say it would have
been standard practice for the committee
to tell a potential whistleblower to
hire an attorney and file a complaint
with an Inspector General CBS News
senior national security analyst says
Fran Townsend was homeland security
advisor to President George W Bush she's
also on the board of trustees at the
McCain Institute were former US special
envoy to Ukraine that's kurt volker his
executive director Volcker resigned from
the State Department post on Friday he
will answer questions today in the house
impeachment inquiry Fran good morning so
it's clear that you know mr. Roker so
we'll start with this he's mentioned
five times in this whistleblower report
what role does he play here in your
opinion well he's got a real burden
today right he's going to appear to give
a deposition he's I expect what his
testimony will be is he was acting as a
career diplomat he was a former
ambassador to NATO his job there was as
a special envoy he was told to make this
introduction for the mayor to these
Ukrainian officials and he was trying to
keep it in State Department channels the
challenge for him is gonna be if that's
what you were doing how is it you didn't
understand what the subject of that
introduction was going to be and didn't
realize that if he at the press they
Rudy Giuliani on the president's behalf
was asking for dirt on Hillary Clinton
or Joe Biden that that was not
appropriate you know there's speculation
that he resigned because he wanted to
speak freely do you have any thoughts
about that yeah I think Kurt did feel
strongly that he wanted to participate
he wanted to be responsive to Congress
he wanted to cooperate that he had
nothing to hide and he didn't want in
any way to be constrained from being
from cooperating with Congress and I
think that's part certainly of what
drove him to decide to resign his
position and the whistleblower report
says that the record of the phone call
between President Trump and the
Ukrainian president was moved to a top
secret server is that normal if that
occurred so if that occurred and that
was handled differently than every other
head of state call yes I'd say that's
unusual these head of state calls are
very carefully guarded right because
heads of state when they talk or did
going to develop a relationship of trust
but what we don't know what the White
House hasn't told us is did they handle
all state of calls in on this special
server because they were concerned about
leaks if they did that I would
understand it if they handle this one
differently that's far more trouble and
you've been on these calls before with
President Bush and in your time in
office another person who's been on
these calls Susan Rice who was Obama's
national security adviser she wrote in a
near Times op-ed that almost everything
about president Trump's conversation
with Ukraine's president violated
protocol do you agree with that look I
think we don't know enough it's like I
don't know whether or not this call was
handled differently in terms of the
server I think look I have never had the
experience where I've been on a call
where President Bush or I'm not even
familiar with any president calling and
asking a foreign leader for a favor
related to a pull an election or a
political matter it's just not the
normal course of things they're normally
asking for bilateral cooperation in a
policy matter is it unusual for
Secretary of State to be on this call no
Secretary of State the national security
adviser perhaps a vice president might
may be on either a separate extension so
in listening why Pompeo didn't say that
and when he was first asked I think that
that's an Internet
that is standing out to a lot of people
I want to move on to the whistleblower
because president Trump has certainly
condemned the whistleblower what are
your thoughts about that
this may be among the most concerning
pieces to me look we as a nation
condemned Snowden because he didn't
follow protocol he didn't hire a lawyer
and file a whistleblower complaint with
the attorney it wouldn't in the
inspector general this individual this
public servant did exactly what they
were supposed to do in the intelligence
community if they had an issue they
followed protocol and now they're being
and the long-term implication of that
gale is every other person who's a
potential whistleblower watches this and
says I'm not I'm not going to do that
yeah what does it mean when the
president uses words like spies and
traitors it's look it's awful right and
I think that this career dedicated
public servant was trying to do the
right thing and it's you've ruined this
individuals career and you've just
law-abiding people throughout the
intelligence community from coming
forward when they see misconduct yeah
and it's interesting Gil regarding
secretary Pompeo the president is saying
the call was perfect but secretary
Pompey who is not saying the same thing
thus far yes Tran thank you very much
thank you